Cameron said today that he would do the
live TV debate with me as long as it
happened earlier than currently planned
that's fine by me I'll do it anytime
anyplace anywhere so I want these TV
debates to happen because i think the
British public deserve it and David
Cameron should now name the date can you
also guarantee that you are committed to
the two older debates involving the
other parties even the Prime Minister
gives the impression that he's not gonna
take part well I want these debates to
happen I want the 7-way debates happen I
want the two-way debates to happen and i
think the British public need them to
happen and frankly David Cameron has
first of all made the excuses about the
greens then the greens were invited then
he talked about Northern Ireland and now
he's saying he doesn't like the timing
of the debate well I'm saying to David
Cameron his type trying to stand up and
be counted because the British public
deserved these debates to happen I want
them to happen and frankly he should
stop making excuses and wriggling and
aren't frustrated to you that it hasn't
happened to debate to date and ma vie
started rehearsing and we started
practicing and if so who's who's making
David Cameron as well I've got many
other things to to do these debates are
important I think the most important
thing is actually for the public you
know I think that these debates happened
last time they happened in 2010 I think
they were a good innovation I think the
public thought they were a good
innovation David Cameron said there are
a good innovation there in a central
part of our democracy well if he thinks
they're an essential part of our
democracy it's time you stop wriggling
he stopped running scared and he
actually said these debates are gonna
happen and he's gonna take part and just
very finely just to be clear you are
committed to having the two debates with
the seven parties including yourself and
their head-to-head and you're perfectly
willing to have that outside of the
election period yes I'll do it earlier
than planned because David Cameron's
made another excuse today saying he
doesn't like the date well if he doesn't
like the date let's move the date let's
make the debates happen